bonjour à tous bienvenue sur les chaînes
parlementaires 45 minutes pour refaire
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
de la semaine bonjean catllar bonjour
vie quelle est cette semaine dans
l'actualité les députés ont voté le
budget rectificatif pour 2014 les
frondeurs sont rentrés dans le rang une
seule abstention côté socialiste mais
ils n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot ils
menacent de ne pas voter le collectif
rectificative de la sécurité sociale
l'actualité politique dominé par la mise
en examen de nicolas sarkozy poursuivi
pour trafic d'influencé corruption
active et recel de violation du secret
professionnel l'ex chef d'état est sorti
de son silence il a dénoncé une
instrumentalisation politique de la
justice et laisse planer le mystère sur
son retour en politique or et puis dans
un autre registre on parlera de jean
jaurès cent ans après sa mort l'artisan
du socialisme français reste une figure
politique cité à droite évidemment à
gauche jaurès est vivant c'est le titre
d'un documentaire qui lui rend hommage
sur notre antenne ce sera le plus de
l'hebdo nous accueillons aujourd'hui
bruno le maire bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous dans parlement hebdo
vous êtes député ump de l'eure et
candidat à la présidence de l'ump l'ump
on va en parler très largement mais
d'abord c'est la tradition je m'oppose
d'entendre ce que pensent de vous
certains de vos collègues écoutez bruno
le maire c'est d'abord un espoir pour
la droite le centre et pour l'ump c'est
l'un de nos éléments les plus brillants
c'est quelqu'un
deux cars et de solide qui va au fond
des dossiers même dans un champ de
ruines fumantes il ya parfois beaucoup
de de gens qui se lèvent pour incarner
la suite au sein d'une droite souvent
brutale c'est un garçon bien élevé si
c'est un député qui est à l'écouté des
besoins et qui ne fait pas de la
politique politicienne en permanence je
souhaite faire avancer la france c'est
bien s'il fait de la politique
politicienne et qui n'a qu'un but c'est
bloqué tous les dossiers tous les
amendements toutes les lois ça va pas
tout changer je partage mes convictions
ça c'est important il n'est pas le seul
il fait partie des deux ou trois qui me
semble devoir être en pole position pour
l'avenir
alors c'est christian paul qui le dit
dans un champ de ruines fumantes bruno
le maire incarne la suite la suite c'est
le rêve quoi
la suite s'est tourné la page avec des
pratiques politiques dont les gens ne
veulent plus ils ont raison les
malversations financières des
comportements politiques qui sont
parfois borderline le cumul des mandats
la possibilité pour les hauts
fonctionnaires de rester haut
fonctionnaire qui deviennent député ou
sénateur je crois que c'est toute cette
vieille politique qu'il faut mettre au
rancart pour inventer quelque chose de
nouveau moi je veux inventer quelque
chose de nouveau en restant fidèle aux
principes de patrick ollier c'était des
principaux gaulliste ça je crois que je
suis très sensible à déclarations de
patrick ollier les principes gaulliste
ou c'est l'intérêt général qui passe
avant l'intérêt particulier où c'est la
nation française qui passe avant des
carrières personnelles c'est ça qui
m'inspire je pense qu'on a besoin de
renouveau aujourd'hui complet dans la
vie politique et je veux le porter dans
la mer inventer quelque chose de nouveau
ça sonne un peu comme rupture je vous
proposais une photo vous allez me dire
de quelle deux hommes politiques vous
sortez plus proche c'est ce qu'on peut
voir cette photo d'un tas mandat nicolas
sarkozy et matteo renzi premier ministre
italien vous savez je suis très même si
j'adore l'italie je suis très français
donc j'ai travaillé que nicolas sarkozy
g très heureux de travailler avec lui
très fier de ce que j'ai fait avec lui
maintenant j'estime qu'on a besoin de 9
à droite seul je veux le porter je pense
qu'on peut vouloir porter du neuf sans
renier son passé aux joueurs ne renie
rien de mon passé mais au moment où
somme quand je vois la crise la
démocratie française quand je vois les
difficultés économiques que les français
ont affronté la montée du chômage la
nécessité de vraiment passé à autre
chose je me dis il faut du neuf je veux
incarner cette nouveauté du 9 mai matteo
renzi en même temps en italie il a fait
aussi un peu de ménage autour de lui
gravitent alimata jeanne dire beaucoup
de charme petit creux semble vite
aviaire c'est ce qu'on dit la politique
française doit rester la politique
française ou alors on va avancer dans la
semaine qui commence avec un
avertissement
avec le medef qui ne menacent de ne pas
aller à la conférence sociale qui
s'ouvre ce lundi au menu des discussions
le conte pénibilité le premier ministre
lui a décidé de reporter ce conte
pénibilité le medef aurait-il gagné la
partie on veut simple crime benameur une
semaine de tensions entre partenaires
sociaux et gouvernement dès lundi pierre
gattaz fait planer une menace le
patronat pour et y laisser sa chaise
vide donc boycotté la conférence sociale
oui si nous n'avons pas clairement cette
semaine les peler les réponses à nos
questions que nous demandons depuis des
mois ces demandes reportait la mise en
place du compte pénibilité d'un an à
janvier 2016 ce fameux compte adopter
lors de la dernière réforme des
retraites
face aux menaces manuel valls eux cèdent
et donne satisfaction au patronat en
annonçant un report partiel en 2016 et
une négociation pour simplifier le code
du travail il le réaffirme ce jeudi le
patronat doit maintenant prendre ses
responsabilités alors maintenant je dis
en vous répondant aux organisations
patronales gelé d'hier dans mon
interview au journal les échos la balle
est dans votre camp plus de posture
engagez-vous et respectez votre parole
mais cette fermeté affichée est trop
tardive pour les syndicats en colère
contre les concessions du premier
ministre au patronat il suffit que le
patronat éternue pour qu'ils lui
apportent la boîte de mouchoirs quoi il
cajole le patronat et les tapes sur les
salariés c'est quand même ça la réalité
aujourd'hui qu'on ne nous parle pas de
dialogue social moi j'appelle ça du
diktat social j'appelle pas ça du
dialogue social
de trahison aussi à la cfdt qui a
fortement soutenu la réforme des
retraites au nom de ce conte pénibilité
laurent berger par le deux mauvais coup
pour le dialogue social et annonce des
tensions lors de la conférence le
premier ministre bruno le maire at il
bien fait de céder sur le conte
pénibilité moi ce qui me désole en
regardant votre reportage qui est bien
fait c'est cette partie de ping pong
permanente entre les partenaires sociaux
les responsables politiques on se
renvoie la balle assez rien n'avance oui
mais ça peut pas continuer comme ça
c'est bien justement le temps qu'il faut
du renouveau ce renouveau c'est ça c'est
réfléchi question n'est pas le compte de
pénibilité savoir si on va avancer dans
la conférence sociale énième conférence
sociale la énième table ronde entre
partenaires sociaux moi j'attends des
décisions la france est au fond du trou
vous avez aujourd'hui des millions de
chômeurs qui attendent un emploi qui
espère un emploi vous avez des millions
de jeunes qui sont désespérés la
situation de leur pays et qui choix se
retrouvent au chômage soit se disent il
vaut mieux partir de france et qu'est ce
que font les partenaires sociaux qu'est
ce que fait le gouvernement qu'est ce
que fait le président de la république
ils se renvoient la balle on se dit on
va peut-être si j' aurais peut-être pas
siéger on va peut-être en décision on en
prendra peut-être pas où est le chef ou
la vision cause la rupture de
l'engagement est ce que ce soit nouveau
et c'est parce que c'est avec qui là les
syndicats il soit autour de la table
vous négociez avec qui dans ces cas là
que le gouvernement prenne ses
responsabilités c'est au gouvernement et
non pas seul car au gouvernement quant
au président de la république de prendre
un certain nombre de décisions si les
partenaires sociaux sont pas capables de
se mettre d'accord vous voyez bien
qu'ils sont comme chien et chat je suis
peut-être pas très psychologue je
comprends avec votre reportage et de ce
que je sais qu'entre la cfdt fo cgt le
medef le torchon brûle est ce qu'ils
peuvent se mettre d'accord non sur quoi
est ce qui pourrait se mettre d'accord
un minimum minimorum qui sera totalement
insuffisant on le voit on le sait bien
dans cette situation là qu'est ce qui
attend le président de la république
pour prendre enfin des décisions son
pacte de responsabilité et dates de caen
14 janvier j'avais dis chiche à l'époque
alors jeté 10 au 14 janvier peut-être
que le 1er février il y aura une
décision j'ai attendu le 1er mars
toujours pas de décision 1er avril
toujours pas de décision on est début
juillet toujours pas de but cision c'est
toujours renvoyée aux calendes grecques
précisément quelle serait la bonne
méthode pour relancer le dialogue social
quand on sait la décision s'est pas
relancé le dialogue social
un sujet n'est pas le dialogue social le
sujet n'est pas la négociation
le sujet n'est pas là par lot
le sujet n'est pas des grandes
conférences le sujet c'est améliorer la
vie des français le sujet c'est que les
français trouvent des emplois le sujet
c'est qu'on fasse baisser le chômage le
sujet c'est que ce combat de formation
en est une ras-le-bol de ces discussions
qui s'éternisent et des décisions qui ne
viennent pas moi je veux une
simplification immédiate sera du travail
ou un allègement immédiat des charges
qui pèsent sur les salaires je veux une
sanctification immédiate de la vie des
entreprises je veux une suppression
immédiate des sièges des seuils sociaux
qui empêche les petites entreprises de
grandir c'est sa décision et c'est ça
une vision en tout cas il a pris une
décision le gouvernement sur le dossier
a très chaud de d'alstom ce qu'il ya eu
donc un nouveau rebondissement
l'autorité des marchés financiers a mis
en garde l'état estimant que sa
stratégie de montée au capital pourrait
ne pas tenir ont en tout cas pour l
obliger à déclencher nos pays va pas
rentrer dans le détail simplement est ce
que pour vous l'état et briques se sont
mis d'accord et sur quoi qu'est-ce que
bouygues auraient obtenir l'échangé le
premier jour de cette décision qui a été
vantée à longueur de journaux à longueur
d'émissions à longueur de réunions
politiques une grande décision je
dénonce cette décision de la montée de
l'état au capital il s'est trompé de
stratégie c'est une mauvaise stratégie
c'est une mauvaise stratégie parce que
ça ne permettra pas à l'état d'orienter
les décisions d'alstom et general
electric ce qui est mille fois plus
puissant que les deux milliards d'euros
que l'état investit dans la boîte ça ne
permettra pas de pérenniser un certain
nombre d'activités stratégiques d'alstom
je pense en particulier à la branche
transport je pense que les incertitudes
restent les mêmes et en troisième lieu
ça fait de l'état la caution de
décisions sur lesquelles il ne pourra
pas intervenir vous savez en chef
étranger nc 2 milliards d'euros c'est
tout simplement que monsieur montebourg
depuis le début de ce dossier veut que
alstom se marie avec siemens
comme il n'a pas eu gain de cause et
bien pour regarder monsieur montebourg
gouvernement françois hollande a dit
allez on va monter au capital d'alstom
on va claquer deux milliards d'euros et
comme ça montebourg restera au
gouvernement de classer milliards
d'euros le maroquin ministériel pour
monsieur montebourg ça fait cher alors
on passe à mardi c'est fini pour la
discussion budgétaire puisque le projet
de loi est soumis au vote
le budget rectificatif a été adopté avec
une large majorité il ya eu une seule
abstention côté socialiste les frondeurs
de la majorité sont finalement rentrés
dans le rang un vote de courage pour
manuel valls compte rendu de séance avec
elisa bartholomé
307 voix pour 232 voix contre et 14
petites abstentions seulement le projet
de loi de finances rectificative pour
2014 a été adopté à une large majorité y
compris par les députés frondeurs 5
milliards d'euros consacrés à trois
millions de ménages qui vont qui était
entré dans l'impôt qui ne laissait pas
pourquoi et qui va en sortir je
considère que c'est bien pourtant
c'était loin d'être gagné pendant toute
la semaine de débats l'ailé gauche du ps
a bataillé pour imposer ces amendements
dans l'hémicycle aucun n'a été adoptée
mais les frondeurs ont tout de même
décidé de soutenir le texte sur les 41
qui s'était abstenue lors du vote sur le
programme de stabilité
seul l'un d'entre eux ne s'est pas
prononcé je dirais que c'est une
cohérence avec le vote que j'avais
exprimé le 29 avril dernier sur le
programme de stabilité
2014-2017 je m'étais abstenu et il m'a
semblé cohérent et naturel de m'abstenir
aujourd'hui la raison essentielle c'est
l'absence de contrepartie au pack de
responsabilité pour le gouvernement et
la majorité
c'est un soulagement on est miss y ait
eu un vrai débat il vraie discussion et
des amendements ces amendements seront
devenus minoritaires clairement et il ya
au bout du compte une très très très
large majorité qui compte c'est le
résultat au bout du compte ce n'est pas
le bruit qui l'emportent c'est la
majorité qui l'emportent mais pour les
le gauche le combat n'est pas terminé
les députés veulent maintenant obtenir
des avancées sur le projet de loi de
financement rectificative de la sécurité
sociale
la bataille s'annonce plus rude
bruno le maire est ce que pour vous les
frondeurs qui font entendre leurs voix
sont dans leur rôle est ce qu ils la
doivent rester dans la majorité qu'est
ce que vous pensez de leurs osez l'art
techniquement bien aimable en leur
donnant ce titre de fondeurs
comme ce sont des fondeurs bien sage qui
se sont vite transformés en courtisans
du pouvoir ils ont manifesté pendant une
journée ou deux et puis ensuite ils se
sont tous couchés rapidement donc c'est
une fronde fonte d'un jour c'est parce
que j'appelle n'oeuvrait fonde sur le
fond ça résout rien des difficultés moi
c'est ce qui m'intéresse le plus c'est
un projet de loi de finances
rectificative contre lequel j'ai voté
parce que il ne résout aucun des
problèmes des français c'est un projet
de loi de finances rectificative c'est
assez unique dans les annales de la
république qui vient corriger des
décisions du même gouvernement c'est à
dire que on avait soumis à l'impôt sur
le revenu un certain nombre de
contribuables on sait de la tension qui
vont qui veut poser un problème et donc
on fait un projet de loi de finances
rectificative pour retirer un certain
nombre de personnes de l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est peut-être vrai franchement
mais non parce qu'au bout du compte
quels sont ceux qui vont payer toujours
les mêmes ceux qui axent leurs impôts
augmenter je parle de la classe moyenne
je parle de des familles nombreuses je
parle de tous ceux qui ont des niveaux
de rémunération modeste mais qui paye
des impôts élevés c'est toujours eux qui
vont trinquer pour les autres très bien
pour ce qu'on était sortis de l'impôt
sur le revenu moi je pense à ceux qui
vous continuer à payer un impôt
confiscatoire en france et sont nombreux
qu'est ce qu'il aurait fallu faire alors
vous auriez prod est quoi parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de cadeaux qui sont qui
sont accordées vous dit ce n'est pas une
bonne chose qu'on oublie la classe je
pense que l'erreur stratégique du
gouvernement c'est d'employer
systématiquement le rabot c'est à dire
de retirer aux uns et aux autres faute
de vraies réformes de structure alors on
gèle les pensions de retraite c'est
injuste on gèle le point des
fonctionnaires le traitement des
fonctionnaires c'est injuste on soumet
un certain nombre de ménages un impôt
sur le revenu toujours plus élevés c'est
injuste on prend un tout petit peu à
tout le monde parce qu'on n'a pas le
courage de faire de vraies grandes
réformes de l'état français des
structures françaises moi c'est ça que
je demande je pense par exemple que
l'état aujourd'hui il est présent dans
un certain nombre d'entreprises
il ya des participations ça n'a aucun
sens prenez les deux milliards d'euros
dans alstom ces deux milliards d'euros
qui sont claqués pour rien prenez des
participations de l'état dans un certain
de l'entreprise privée où il est caution
de décisions sur lesquelles il n'a
aucune influence ça ne sert à rien
est-ce qu il encore utile que aéroports
de paris soit une entreprise publique
gaspillage pourvoi c'est en tout cas de
l'argent qui est mal placée quand on a
aujourd'hui de telles difficultés
financières mais plutôt que de prendre
ou retraités de prendre aux
fonctionnaires le de prendre aux ménages
modestes de prendre aux familles avec le
quotient familial qu'aujourd'hui pour
toutes les familles de france signifie
une augmentation massive de leurs impôts
on ferait mieux d'avoir le courage que
n'a pas françois hollande et que n'a pas
manuel valls d'engager un vrai
changement de l'état une vraie
redéfinition de son périmètre est
d'avoir un état qui se concentre sur ses
seules missions essentielles la sécurité
la justice l'éducation c'est ça que
cette grossesse si les gens vous revenez
au pouvoir et que si jamais vous avez
dit d'ordre ump jean françois copé à
l'époque disait qu' il avait prévu de
gouverner par ordonnance est-ce que vous
reprendriez ce schéma aujourd'hui je
pense qu'il faut prendre des décisions
rapides donc pas nécessairement par
ordonnance je pense qu'on peut prendre
des décisions rapides sans passer
forcément par les ordonnances c'est que
je crois surtout c'est que au delà des
méthodes ce qui compte c'est que on
explique aux français où nous voulons
aller moi je veux pas infliger une purge
au français je veux simplement que
chaque français vivent mieux j'ai
proposé il ya plus de trois ans une
réforme de l'indemnisation du chômage
c'était pas pour taper contre les
chômeurs c'était pour aider les chômeurs
c'est pour que on économise sur
l'indemnisation pour mettre de l'argent
sur la formation et le placement des
chômeurs ça c'est des changements
structurels et ça améliore au bout du
compte la vie des français je pense à la
vie des français on passe à mercredi
nicolas sarkozy qui revient sous les
feux des projecteurs
il a parlé mercredi soir sur tf 1 et
europe1 20 minutes d'interview en forme
de réquisitoire contre les juges qui
l'ont mis en examen et contre l'exécutif
nicolas sarkozy a aussi laissé entendre
qu'il pourrait revenir bientôt en
politique les inverse tholomé garde à
vue compte de campagne retour en
politique nicolas sarkozy est largement
revenu sur les affaires qui le
concernent sur la forme l'ancien chef de
l'état se dit victime des méthodes de la
justice à son égard est il normal
que je sois écouter dans mes
conversations les plus intimes
depuis le mois de septembre de l'année
dernière est il normal que je sois placé
en garde à vue pendant 15 heures
sous la surveillance d'ailleurs deux
policiers qui ont fait remarquablement
leur travail qui bien sûr je n'ai rien à
reprocher mais ne pouvait-on pas me
convoquer pour que je réponde aux
questions des juges à l'issue de sa
garde à vue nicolas sarkozy a été mis en
examen autre affaire qui concerne l'ump
bygmalion et le financement de sa
campagne en 2012 là encore l'ancien chef
de l'état se défend et refuse d'admettre
un dépassement en ce qui concerne ma
campagne je le dis à tous ceux qui m'ont
soutenu il n'y a jamais le moindre
système de double facturation
que les 17 millions qu'on prétend
dépendent de ma campagne qui ont été
cachés c'est une folie personne jamais
ne peut imaginer que les enquêteurs
pensaient qu'en institut sionnel où la
commission des comptes de campagne soit
passé au dans ses valises et autres
thématiques un éventuel retour en
politique via une candidature à la
présidence de l'ump à l'automne prochain
sur cette question nicolas sarkozy
laisse planer le doute sur ses
intentions j'aurais a décidé après un
temps de réflexion
à la fin du mois d'août au début du mois
de septembre de ce que je devrais faire
une vingtaine de minutes d'interview et
un objectif à atteindre pour l'ancien
président se défendre et préparer son
retour auprès des français sonné le
maire vous imaginez qu'on a beaucoup de
questions à vous poser sur la défense
sur l'avenir de l'ump c'est notre zone
de la semaine
nous aider à y voir plus clair frédéric
dabi nous a rejoint le directeur adjoint
de l'institut de sondage ifop bonjour
cas d'éric bonjour je m'adressais
d'abord à bruno le maire évidemment pour
répondre à cette question de temps vous
croyez à la théorie du complot nicolas
sarkozy je suis pas un adepte de la
théorie du complot moi j'ai dit mon
amitié et mon soutien à nicolas sarkozy
et je redis mon amitié je redis mon
soutien à nicolas sarkozy je pense que
il a traversé des heures et des moments
qui sont extrêmement difficiles j'ai été
fier du travail que j'ai fait à ses
côtés pendant quatre ans comme ministre
et donc je la sueur de cette amitié et
de ce soutien ensuite des décisions de
justice la justice elle passe elle est
la même pour tous là pas une justice des
puissants une justice des faibles elle
la même pour tous qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la ligne de défense de nicolas
de nicolas sarkozy qui compare son cas
notamment à celui de jérôme cahuzac
moi je fais pas de comparaison je ne
critique pas
juge je pense que l'institution
judiciaire fait son travail et que la
responsabilité politique aujourd'hui
c'est de laisser l'institution
judiciaire faire son travail le plus
sereinement possible
vous savez je suis frappé par le climat
politique qui règne aujourd'hui en
france par cette nervosité par cette
violence parfois je pense qu'on a besoin
de sérénité notre débat politique et de
très grande volonté apporter un
changement complet dans notre
fonctionnement démocratique dans nos
choix économiques dans nos choix sociaux
mais de la sérénité et la sérénité c'est
respecter le rôle de chacun je veux
entendre votre opinion vous sur nicolas
sarkozy est ce que vous avez jugé qu'il
s'adressait tout d'abord à son camp et
rien qu'à son camp alors il est trop tôt
pour le dire il faut être prudent cette
affaire est en cours mais il ya toutes
les chances que envers toutes les
péripéties judiciaires qu'a connu
nicolas sarkozy depuis son départ de
l'elysée que ça renforce un double
décalage un décalage entre l'ensemble
des français dans toutes les enquêtes
une majorité très nette de français ne
souhaite pas un autour de nicolas
sarkozy y compris un électeur de droite
sur deux et la france des sympathisants
ump je crois bien des sympathisants pas
des adhérents qui ce qu'ils se
prononceront qui voteront le 29 novembre
dans l'élection pour laquelle
le maire et candidat la france des
sympathisants ump souhaitent ardemment
le retour de nicolas sarkozy est elle
cette france-là ses sympathisants ump
comprennent où on cette logique de
l'acharnement politique est politique
politico pardon judiciaire qui est au
coeur de leur perception sur ce qui se
passe pour nicolas sarkozy donc de ce
point de vue là les choses devraient
rester en l'état mais il est trop tôt
pour le dire est ce que dans de telles
conditions avec autant d'affaires de
soupçons en tout cas qui pèse sur
nicolas sarkozy il peut encore revenir
oui
je vous réponde qu'elle serait un
obstacle à son retour c'est à
l'originalité et moi je respecte ce
qu'il a dit sur tf1 il ya quelques jours
il se donne un temps de réflexion et il
décidera qui prenne son temps de
réflexion ensuite qu'il décide est qu'il
annonce sa décision à tous les français
moi je veux offrir un autre choix aux
militants lui aime justement c'est quoi
la différence entre vous et nicolas
sarkozy je pense que les différences
elle se voit assez spontanément je pense
que les gens la connaissent avoir
regardé sur le fonctionnement
démocratique
je n'ai jamais cumuler les mandats est
toujours refusé le cumul des mandats
nicolas sarkozy et position qui est
différente j'ai toujours proposé qu'on
limite le nombre de mandats
parlementaires dans le temps c'est aussi
une singularité j'ai démissionné de la
fonction publique c'est une singularité
par rapport à ce qui a été fait c'est ça
qui les aura la différence entre vous et
nikola girke opposés sur le parti une
transparence financière totale j'ai
proposé une gestion des comptes
différente j'ai proposé qu'on fasse un
appel d'offres systématiques dès qu'il y
ait un contrat important pour l'ump
nicolas sarkozy a déjà été président de
l'ump en 2004
toutes les mesures que je propose elles
n'ont pas été mises en place donc ce que
je propose est l'affairé de l'homme du
renouveau c'est ça je dis simplement que
je veux offrir aux militants une
alternative un autre choix est ce que
vous voulez une tête nouvelle au sommet
de l'ump est ce que vous voulez un
président qui rassemble
est ce que vous voulez quelqu'un qui est
prêt à porter un changement complet pour
la vie politique française pour notre
démocratie pour notre système économique
et social c'est ce que je propose c'est
pas une candidature contre nicolas
sarkozy la preuve en est que je me suis
porté candidat le 11 juin c'était il ya
très longtemps bien avant les affaires
bien avant la convocation nicolas
sarkozy ce n'est pas une candidature
contre nicolas sarkozy c'est une
candidature pour le renouveau et je dis
aux militants si vous voulez un autre
choix si vous voulez une autre
possibilité un président nouveau
différent et bien voté pour moi est ce
que les militants sont prêts à entendre
ce discours est ce qu'ils veulent eux
aussi du renouveau ou alors est ce qu'il
reste très fidélisant
il n'y a pas d' enquête auprès des
militants ont indiqué les militants
veulent gagner et veulent surtout voir
cette image de l'ump se redresser ce qui
a une affaire qui a eu un impact déjà
d'ores et déjà massif sur l'image de
l'ump c'est la sphère bygmalion dans une
enquête ifop jdd réalisée au lendemain
des premières révélations l'ump auprès
des sympathisants perd 30 points sur sa
capacité à avoir un peu un projet
alternatif au parti socialiste perd 25
points c'est des chiffres vertigineux
tous à proximité aux préoccupations des
français l'ump est en vase clos et
autocentrée quand on attend d'elle et
les a et c'est une attente très forte
des adhérents qu'elle cogne si je puis
dire le gouvernement et qu'elle propose
un projet d'alternance un projet
asiatique et aujourd'hui c'est le front
national qui à ce rôle là alors pour
reprendre ce que vient pour revenir sur
ce cas dit à bord de mer il ya une vraie
différence d'image entre nicolas sarkozy
et bruno le maire nicolas sarkozy est
une figure il faut le dire repoussoir
auprès d'une majorité de français juge
le design ne veulent pas son retour à
une grande majorité
des militants et des sympathisants plus
on est au centre
historique nucléaire de la droite forte
dur plus nicolas sarkozy a du succès
bruno le maire auprès de l'ensemble des
français et et auprès des sympathisants
ump et le leader politique de l'ump qui
a le plus petit nombre de mauvaises
opinions il n'est pas connu par
l'ensemble des français il ya encore une
popularité en construction mais quand
quand il est connu il n'a pas cette
figure repoussoir qu'à nicolas sarkozy
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui mais il
faut voir comment ces affaires vont être
digérée auprès des militants ump auprès
des sympathisants nicolas sarkozy reste
incontournable bruno le maire sur la
ferme une mallyon sur les autres
affaires ne vaudrait-il mieux pas pour
votre parti que nicolas sarkozy se
tiennent à l'écart une rouge 3 la
démocratie et donc je crois que chacun
est libre de se porter candidat si
nicolas sarkozy veut se porter candidat
il le dira il le fera sa demi-heure
examen aucune difficulté ce qui me pose
une difficulté en revanche c'est quand
on me dit mais tout est joué d'avancé
le nicolas sarkozy à la faveur de tous
les militants ump donc plus prudent
c'est même pas la peine de concourir moi
je vous dirai ce que c'est la peine
d'aller concourir si nicolas sarkozy
revient parce qu'on se dit qu'il gagnera
finalement après des mises en pause il
est question je vais à l'élection à la
présidence de l'ump pour gagner face
alors que la sarkozie duration cissé
face à nicolas sarkozy ce sera face à
nicolas sarkozy si c'est face à d'autres
candidats ce sera face à d'autres
candidats je crois démocratie j'aime la
démocratie j'aime le débat démocratique
on verra qui les militants voudront
porter à leur tête ils veulent un party
9 je pense que c'est bien d'avoir
une image 9 et à président 9 ses
sympathisants ses militants voulaient
rencontrer tous les jours puisque vous
êtes d'où vous partez un peu partout là
encore maintenant demain où l'un
est ce que vous pensez que leur coeur
reste à nicolas qui est à nicolas
sarkozy qui sont prêts les militants
échange d'une oeuvre très simple ils
veulent d'avant du rassemblement et
c'est pour ça que vous ne m'entendrez
pas dire un mot négatif ou critique sur
qui que ce soit l'ump parce que je veux
être un président qui rassemble toute
l'ump toutes les sensibilités du pays
veulent d'abord lors ensablement et
qu'on arrête avec les critiques de
personnes avec la guerre des châteaux
d'eau qu'ils veulent du deuxième but les
candidats veulent on est bien mieux
aujourd'hui ont pris un pas de côté face
à nicolas sarkozy ou encore mais chacun
est libre de sa position la mienne elle
est claire
il n'y a aucune difficulté d'avoir à
côté de moi d'autres candidats fût ce un
ancien président de la république je
pense que ce qui est bon pour ma famille
politique c'est tourner la page avec de
vieilles pratiques politiques passées et
de mettre un homme neuf à sa tête je
veux être cet homme là c'est pour ça que
je me bats et je me battrai jusqu'au
bout jusqu'à la dernière minute de la
campagne je suis en campagne tous les
jours oullins hier chez michel terrot ce
soir chez film gosselin dans l'amant j'y
prends un immense plaisir parce que je
vois les militants je discute avec eux
et je sens qu'ils veulent ils veulent
quelque chose qui leur permettent de
gagner dans les années qui viennent face
à un pouvoir socialiste qui met la
france plus bas que terre c'est ça la
préoccupation majeure et ils ont bien
raison avec damier pour conclure oui
c'est vrai qu'il faut être extrêmement
prudents pour parler à la place des
militants ump ils ne sont pas fondés
dans les enquêtes d'opinion on parle qu
on ne veut on interroge que des
sympathisants ump
prudent sur l'issue du congrès du 29
novembre je vous rappellerai ce qui
s'est passé en novembre 2012 où des
enquêtes d'opinion fait auprès des
sympathisants ump
prédisent à une fortune nette victoire
pour françois fillon sait pas ce qui
s'était passé on est sur une campagne
interne le danger pour l'ump pendant
cette campagne interne c'est que les
français beaucoup de français aient le
sentiment que l'ump ne leur parle plus
et ne s'adressent qu'à sa base merci
beaucoup aux frédéric dabi d'avoir été
avec nous on va continuer sur ce thème
avec vous au bruno l'hommage propose de
réécouter ce qu'a dit manuel valls qui
avait parlé de faits graves
concernant la mise en examen de nicolas
sarkozy qu'en sait-il at il eu accès au
dossier a répondu a répondu nicolas
sarkozy écoutez la contre attaque de
manuel valls au micro de dents dans les
couloirs du sénat écoutez prendre les
mots ils sont importants j'ai rappelé
que les faits qui étaient reprochés à
certains nombre de personnes étaient
était grave j'ai rappelé que les
personnalités en cause faisait que c'est
fait d'ailleurs vous en parlez vous même
faisait que ces faits étaient étaient
graves mais géré appelés aussitôt ont
pas de fausse querelle pas de fausse
polémique les deux principes que sont la
présomption d'innocence et
l'indépendance de la justice les juges
doit pouvoir travailler dans la sérénité
sérénité vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
manuel valls avait ou pas
je trouve les propos de manuel valls
à la suite de la mise en examen de
nicolas sarkozy proprement scandaleux il
est premier ministre de la république
française
il est le garant de l'indépendance de la
justice de la séparation des pouvoirs il
a dit les faits sont graves comment
sait-il que ce sont des faits pour
l'instant c'est uniquement des
explications et est volée bien sûr
parler des chefs d'inculpation et la
mise en examen ou un sens il a dit les
faits sont graves il les connaît les
faits il sait ce qui s'est passé il juge
la place de la justice
les propos de monsieur valls sont
inacceptables
c'est aujourd'hui que tient avec dans
l'actualité notamment ce qui se passe au
sénat séance très agitée puisque les
territoires acquis sont et territoires
sont est de retour au palais du
luxembourg
les sénateurs sont toujours opposés la
nouvelle carte des régions de cette
réforme des territoires ils ont fait
entendre au sénat mais entendu ils font
tout ce qu'ils peuvent en tout cas pour
retarder l'examen s'est passé devant le
conseil constitutionnel demande de
référendum qui n'a pas abouti reportage
avec les frondeurs du sénat avec paul
bouffard prêts à les défendre les
territoires comme d'habitude
l'enjeu proposer un référendum sur la
réforme territoriale une solution
proposée par les communistes l'ump le
groupe rdse qui constitue grâce à cet
accord sur le sujet une majorité c'est
quelque chose qui touche à et aux
institutions de proximité de nos
concitoyens donc il est normal dès lors
qu'on ne touche que nous demandons que
la vie soit demander à nos concitoyens
c'est l'utilisation du règlement de
notre assemblée en l'occurrence au sénat
nous sommes une république parlementaire
le gouvernement le droit d'avoir des
idées et nous avons le devoir de
défendre les nôtres le débat en séance
peut donc commencer et c'est pierre-yves
collombat membres du groupe rdse qui est
chargé de porter la parole des partisans
du référendum nous avons conscience
qu'il s'agit d'un acte grave mais vu
l'enjeu de la réforme proposée est le
caractère peu probants des arguments
sensés la justifier voire l'absence
d'arguments
quoi de plus normal que de demander aux
premiers concernés les français de
trancher face à lui michel delbarre le
rapporteur de la commission spéciale du
sénat sur cette réforme qui non sans
humour dénonce le pourrissement de la
situation
le seul objectif était de ralentir les
choses et comme ça me paraît être le
seul objectif de plusieurs d'entre vous
sachez que
je suis
intimement convaincu que nous sommes
appelés à nous revoir c'est ensuite au
tour du ministre de l'intérieur
d'attaquer ce qu'ils considèrent comme
des incohérences si l'on estime que ce
texte n'est pas digne du sénat parce que
les travaux préparatoires n'ont pas été
porté suffisamment loin alors comment
admettre qu'ils puissent être digne du
peuple si c'est le souci du peuple et de
l'intérêt général qui préside au dépôt
d'une motion référendaire j'avoue que
j'ai énormément de mal à accéder au
raisonnement je le trouve vicié jusqu'au
bout les opposants à la réforme joue la
montre multipliant les explications de
vote alors que les positions sur le
sujet sont connues un baroud d'honneur
qui ne devrait pas suffire à faire
échouer le projet du gouvernement qui
s'appuiera une fois de plus sur
l'assemblée nationale pour le faire
adopter la loi nous le maire de vous
soumettre une petite phrase dixit
jacques attali c'était le journal du
dimanche
le dimanche dernier la france est une
juxtaposition de rentiers et de
corporatisme et dedans il inclut le
sénat c'est l'immobilisme l'a fait ce
qu'on voit non je trouve que le sénat
est plutôt sage sur cette question moi
je propose qu'on réduise la taille du
sénat un sénateur par département sans
un sénateur se serait largement
suffisant on sa valeur mais l'air ça je
suis pas sûr que ça leur plaise mais je
pense que ça peut plaire aux français ce
qui est pour moi l'essentiel et je pense
que ça permettra à l'institution du
sénat de rester forte et respectée sur
ce nombre de députés ont réduit aussi
dont le député à 400 c'est la
proposition que je fais depuis
maintenant près de deux ans
mais sur ce sujet là on touche à
l'identité de la france les régions
c'est l'identité de la france c'est la
méthode qui n'est pas bonne c'est le
sens hollande tout seul dans son coin
qui prend sa paire de ciseaux qui
découpent les territoires en écoutant
évidemment d'abord les avis de ses amis
politiques de madame ségolène royal par
exemple et qui fait des découpages qui
sont parfois hasardeuse convoyer ces
grande région centre qui met ensemble
chartres et la rochelle on a mieux de
s'étonner de se dire que tout ça est un
peu de bric et de broc donc la méthode
est mauvaise et quand la méthode est
mauvaise et bien la réforme ne marche
pas les départements vous en faites quoi
l'idée d'avoir un redécoupage des
régions oui l'idée de fusionner les
conseils généraux et les conseils
régionaux oui ça permet de simplifier ça
permet de faire des économies ça permet
d'avoir une structure cérébrale plus
simple et plus lisible on les supprime
accord on supprime les conseils généraux
mais pourquoi effiloché cette réforme
entre 2014 et 2022 honnêtement ça n'a
aucun sens pourquoi commencer par
découper dans un petit bureau de
l'elysée plutôt que de compte culte et
les français aient au moins de consulter
des sénateurs ou les députés la méthode
n'est pas la bonne et ce qui fait que
cette réforme territoriale est très mal
partie c'est qu'on est parti du mauvais
pied en décidant tout seul dans son coin
monsieur hollande de ce que serait la
carte territoriale ou de consulter des
français le gouvernement doit tout
reprendre à zéro sur ce dossier où nous
reprendre à zéro en termes de méthode et
parce que regarder sacré vous savez
devrait frictions et de vraies
interrogations a été les toits chez moi
en normandie ont fait la fusion de la
haute et de la basse normandie la
réclament depuis dix ans donc tant mieux
mais certains disent il faudrait
adjoindre la picardie il ya des picards
qui en valent des picards qui n'en
veulent pas moi je suis pas favorable à
ce qu'on met aussi et la picardie mais
écoutons les gens quand je suis tombé
j'ai demandé en normandie un référendum
pour qu'on sache si les normands étaient
d'accord avec la proposition que je fais
depuis maintenant près de dix ans fusion
de la haute et de la basse normandie et
constitution d'une des plus belles
régions de france la normandie alors on
va parler de notre personnalité qui fait
un peu polémique jacques toubon qui
devrait être selon toute logique nommé
défenseur des droits l'ex garde des
sceaux de jacques chirac a été
auditionné cette semaine par la
commission des lois de l'assemblée qui
se prononcera avec les sénateurs la
semaine prochaine
il n'a pas attendu qu'on lui pose la
question dès les premières minutes de
son audition jacques toubon répond à
ceux qui l'accusent d'être illégitime au
poste de défenseur des droits
abolitionniste de raison et de coeur
j'ai fait campagne en 1980 derrière
jacques chirac qui s'est prononcé pour
l'abolition de la peine de mort devant
les électeurs comme lui et 15 autres
députés rpr j'ai voté l'article premier
du projet de loi qui abolit c'est la
peine de mort en france mais je n'ai pas
voté pour l'ensemble du texte car notre
proposition d'une peine de remplacement
avait été rejetée par robert badinter
proposé par françois hollande la
candidature de l'ex garde des sceaux de
jacques chirac est très contestée à
gauche mais deux députés socialistes
yann galut et alexis bachelez ont appelé
leurs collègues à rejeter massivement sa
nomination pensez vous être
assez consensuel assez rassembleur pour
occuper cette formidable fonction de je
dirais défenseur de droits autre
parcours politique ne plaident pas en
faveur d'une telle fonction malgré le
brillant plaidoyer que vous avez fait
prendre au mot tout à l'heure je
coronado
si ici dans cette commission
certains me font confiance
je m'efforcerai comme je les dis à la
fin de justifier leur confiance
si d'autres ne me font pas confiance
je m'efforcerai pendant toutes mes
fonctions
de leur démontrer qu'ils avaient tort la
décision finale sera connue le 9 juillet
prochain lorsque les sénateurs entendre
ont à leur tour le candidat une majorité
des trois cinquièmes des parlementaires
est nécessaire pour que la nomination de
jacques toubon soit rejetée autant dire
que les jeux sont quasiment faits
les jeux sont quasiment faits les deux
commissions vont quand même voter est-ce
que sur la personnalité de jacques
toubon sur les positions qu'il a pu
prendre à l'époque est ce que pour vous
c'est ses positions sur la peine de mort
sur l'homosexualité position qu'il a
quand même expliqué est ce que c'est un
obstacle à sa nomination à ce poste qui
implique quand même par une personnalité
consensuelle je connais très bien
jacques toubon
je vous dire c'est très simple pour moi
c'est un homme bien c'est un homme bien
c'est un homme de culture c'est un homme
qui a occupé un certain nombre de postes
notamment sur la cité de l'immigration
avec beaucoup de talent je trouve qu'il
mérite largement ce poste de défenseur
des droits la pris des positions sur la
peine de mort par exemple avec lesquels
je ne suis pas d'accord bien entendu
enfin ça remonte à des années des années
ont peu évolué dans sa réflexion
politique ont peu évolué dans ses
positions donc je comprends pas très
bien le procès qui est fait à jacques
toubon par certains pour moi c'est un
procès strictement politiciens c'est un
petit peu dur pour justement se bat un
peu contre françois hollande notamment
celle de la majorité actuelle oui je
pense qu'il peut servir d'intermédiaire
comptes avec françois hollande mais moi
je vous le redis jacques tout - talent
homme bien qui mérite largement sa
domination comme défenseur des styles
très courte sur ces propositions il
propose contrôles au faciès notamment
des policiers vous êtes d'accord ou pas
j'ai pas regardé ces propositions la
pollution droit de vote des étrangers
aux élections locales j'y suis
totalement opposé je suis totalement
opposé au droit de vote des étrangers
aux élections locales a nommé dina
jeanne ebori c'est un homme bien et
comme chez son frère de conviction que
je ne partage pas donné droit de vote
aux étrangers aux élections locales
c'est affaiblir un peu plus la nation
française et faire un peu plus le jeu du
communautarisme aujourd'hui notre pays à
un choix décisif à faire entre défendre
la nation ou défendre les communautés je
serai toujours toujours du côté de ceux
qui défendent la nation soit avec un
petit peu d'histoire
et 100 ans après sa mort jean jaurès est
vivant c'est ce que nous disent deux
historiens qu'ils y ont consacré un
grand documentaire un grand documentaire
donc à cet ancien député bâtisseurs du
socialisme français simon barbarie nous
en montre quelques extraits regardez
c'est un homme qui se bat pour que
l'humanité soit plus j'y mets sont ans
après sa mort jean jaurès est plus que
jamais présents dans notre quotidien
à gauche bien sûr à droite et même à
l'extrême droite il est devenu une
référence historique et politique
incontournable pourquoi autant
d'évocations un siècle après sa tragique
disparition que peut-il encore bien nous
dire c'est la question à laquelle a
voulu répondre l'historien jean noël
jeanneney dont le documentaire jaurès et
vivant laïcité justice défense des
opprimés autant de thèmes qui dépasse
les clivages et qui font de lui plus que
jamais un mythe républicain qui rejoint
s'occupe réellement de l'avenir de la
moitié de la population
qui vote peu qu'ils se mobilisent peu
qui est nationalisé de fait que ce pass
chômage de fait même par le lieu
d'habitation
aaron dhabi jaurès la pointe à robert un
repère oui le repaire d'un homme
toujours en avance sur son temps et pour
comprendre ce personnage le documentaire
s'attache à nous replonger dans une
époque où liberté égalité fraternité
suscitait encore la ferveur et
l'espérance les la révolution elle doit
avoir lieu dans les esprits et elle doit
commencer par l'instruction publique si
nous voulons la justice et bien il faut
d'abord éduquer le peuple a aimé sa
propre liberté et être capable de la
construire
symbole de justice de progrès et de paix
jean jaurès fait partie des plus beaux
oripeaux d'une époque révolue à travers
cette illustration en images de ses
combats politiques ce documentaire nous
rappelle que la force de l'histoire
c'est bien d'éclairer les luttes civique
du présent on alors c'est une figure
historique qui est cité à gauche à
droite même à l'extrême droite que
symbolise pour vous jean jaurès dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui je respecte toujours
les hommes d'engagement une conviction
et jean jaurès est un homme d'engagement
et de conviction ensuite je vous cache
pas que je suis un peu gêné par la
récupération dont il fait l'objet très
franchement moi j'ai pas des idées de
jean jaurès sur beaucoup de sujets et je
préfère le dire clairement je suis
gaulliste j'ai plus de référence pour de
gaulle que pour jaurès et je pense qu'on
peut pas tout mélanger tout le temps
cette espèce de mélange permanent où
tout se vaut où tout a exactement la
même valeur moi c'est pas mon truc on ne
voit pas forcément de change reste dans
votre discours on ne retrouvera pas jean
jaurès ont beau disque week-end soit le
respect que j'ai pour lui merci en tout
cas bruno le maire d'avoir été l'invité
de par le manque d'occasions surtout la
semaine prochaine avec plaisir sur les
chaînes parlementaires merci à vous pour
votre fidélité et à très vite tiens
tiens
se renseigner sur les programmes
voir